might we be about to get some really
solid news about the new stargate series
and actually get names to go with a lot
of the rumors
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
so before
[Music]
so before i get started i'm going to say
this is a room
um i do as you know if you're a regular
sidetracker speak to several people that
work in around mgm and amazon these are
not hype executives some of them have
quite menial jobs some of them are
created types some of them work in the
legal department but all of them are
gators just like me and you they love
stargate and wanted to return just as
much as me and you and they leak me
little bits of information
now the rumor i'm hearing has come from
two different sources and a third that
says even though he hasn't heard it
himself he would be able to confirm it
for me um very soon if they get to the
point of actually creating a contract
and paying them to do something but that
he actually genuinely believes it
probably is true and he has heard
something along these lines before i'm
going to tell you who these people are
in just one second but just before i do
i just want to reiterate that this would
be to do with a tv series not the movie
that is also apparently being seriously
considered a movie that would be a
sequel to the original stargate movie
that would potentially star kurt russell
and that would even though it wouldn't
pee on canon of sg1 sgu and sga would as
i say be a sequel to the original film
and be very much a stand-alone project
by the way don't forget to subscribe
please like the video and if you do
enjoy the content please consider
hitting the join button and becoming a
fully fledged side tracker who is it and
what are they being asked to do
mark fergus and hawk ostby
developed and wrote and produced the
expanse they've also written iron man
children of men and many many other
projects according to my source they are
being approached to develop a new
stargate series or at very least to put
a proposal together for what they
envisage the stargaze series should look
like
now i have told you a few months ago
that amazon went into mgm and they found
out that it was basically a complete
mess but they did put a small team
together that started to put proposals
forward for how they would like to move
forwards with certain projects so there
is a team working on bond there is a
team working on stargate and there is a
team working on loads and loads of other
projects mgm had in the pipeline the
team that is working on the project have
identified mark fergus and hawkosby
[ __ ] great name
as potential people that could come in
and really do something new now i know
what you're thinking and please don't
shoot the messenger but the brad wright
project has never been loved by amazon
not the writing they respect his writing
and they expect his creative vision but
they never really liked where
he was taking stargate they didn't like
how it fitted into the overall universe
and
to be honest i've been telling you nine
months that they didn't really like this
project so it shouldn't really be a
surprise that we still have no stargate
but what am i being told about these two
fellas and what are they actually going
to be doing
well as i say initially it is just going
to be
a conversation they would like
mark fergus and hor cosby
to actually develop something
along a certain set of principles now
i've been told they will have been given
a
memo an idea of where their project
wants to go a certain amount of
direction or maybe like a set of rules
now these rules they have to follow
would be along the lines of sg1 sga and
sgu still need to be canon but that
you're allowed to mess with certain
things there are certain things that are
no go so things that are fine
they will take that set of rules and
they will put a proposal forwards for
what they think stargate should look
like in the future now that doesn't
necessarily mean that these two fellows
will come on as show runners executive
producers or anything else the initial
conversation is just
if you were to do this what would it
look like
i'm told that that process can take on
its own a few months mark fergus and
hawkesby are going to want to do
significant research i personally don't
know if they're stargate fans they might
me they might not be i don't know
but
if they're not they're gonna have to do
a lot of research
16 series they're gonna have to look at
um
so that's gonna be the first stage
they're then gonna have to come up with
an idea and create the proposal that it
could take months
i think though that if this does go
ahead um i'm i'm told that we're only at
the stage of that it's been suggested
and but they have had positive response
amazon but if this does go ahead i think
we will hear positive news on this i
think we will see that press release we
will see something appear on imdb
or something along those lines
i should also say that both of these
fellas have actually got quite a lot of
projects on the go already two of which
a tv series they're supposedly producing
but only actually one project is in
production
all of the other projects are just stuff
that they're working on their stuff in
development none of them will
necessarily ever see the light of day
so
there is nothing that i can see on their
imdb list to stop them potentially doing
this stargate project also it may be
something that they just come in and
develop like they did with the expanse
they would develop it maybe write a few
episodes maybe executive produce but
somebody else will then come in as the
showrunner once a direction has been set
and once they know exactly where they're
going i am a little bit surprised that
i'm hearing news about people being
suggested for a development project
before we actually do have a showrunner
but perhaps that is good news for brad
wright because maybe the idea still is
for brad wright to be the showrunner but
for someone else to come in and maybe
take the show in a slightly different
direction
i think to be honest though we would
know about that if it was true because i
think that would have been leaked um and
to be honest if that's true i'd be very
surprised if brad didn't know that
already and from his twitter feed it
doesn't suggest he does
so
don't shoot the messenger but we'll see
what that means in another video there
is of course another possibility that
when they come back with a proposal if
the proposal is liked that these two
could be approached to showroom
um they're a team that works together
very very well they've worked on loads
and loads of projects over the years and
they seem to have a really good work
relationship per taps perhaps that is a
way forward and it would be a step up
for these guys it would be a different
direction but to me all the best show
runners are the writers and the
developers of series that's one of the
reasons why brad wright was such a great
show runner
one of the things i did ask when i was
told about this news that mark fergus
and hawk used to be are being pushed
forward to develop a new series is
what's the time frame could we be
looking at
uh my source actually told me that he
would be very surprised astounded in
fact that if this was kept secret for
more than a couple of months that this
story about these guys trying to develop
a new series will leak out and we will
actually get official response from
amazon it won't just be rumors on videos
like this
but i then pushed further to say well
how long until we actually get to see a
series
the answer very simply 12 months
minimum
so he was looking at six months for
development and then six months to go
into pre-production so i don't mean 12
months until it's on our screens i mean
12 months until they even start making
the show
so in that case we're looking at
probably early 2024 until this is going
to make our screens
so guys get in the comments tell me what
you think about this rumor and i'm going
to keep saying rumor because it has not
been confirmed
but if these guys were to go away and
were to develop a new stargaze series
what do you think
is it brad right or bust or actually do
you think a new direction might not be
the worst idea in the world also if you
are new to the channel please like and
subscribe hit that bell notification
also please consider becoming a fully
fledged psy tracker if you really enjoy
the content also you can go to
sci-trek.com for merchandise like we
want stargate t-shirts mugs and
everything else
as always guys please stay safe
[Music]
you